how would you feel if tom riddle's
middle name was
elvis or his first name romeo
yep these are actual harry potter
translations
international versions of the wizarding
world made some pretty big changes
but the us movie adaptations of the uk
book series might be the worst offenders
some of the changes between the movies
and the books can be straight up
confusing
for one what about sirius's last words
in the books they were said to bellatrix
not harry but the movie completely
changed that for one last tearjerker
moment
there's plenty more where that came from
so here are some of the most
massive changes between different
versions of harry potter
in the original book we are told that
six professors and the headmaster were
tasked with setting up enchantments to
protect the sorceress stone
in the u.s film we only get to see five
challenges completed
the three-headed dog devil snare
enchanted keys
wizard's chess and the mirror of arasad
what's missing though
is a battle with professor quirrell's
second troll
the first of which was defeated earlier
in the bathrooms and
professor snape's potion riddle
challenge the challenges were probably
cut for time
plus we did get to see one troll fight
so why have two
but cutting the scene does ignore the
fact that it was supposed to be seven
because seven is considered a magical
number five challenges though
time efficient but not quite so magical
sirius's last scene will always haunt us
but it became very different once it was
adapted for a u.s audience
on paper sirius's last words were
actually spoken to bellatrix as they
fight
he tells her come on you can do better
than that but in the movie
they needed a touching final moment
between harry and his godfather
before he falls through the veil sirius
turns to harry and says
that's one game ouch that one hurts
not only does he see his best friend and
his godson but the two of them will
never be able to develop a real
relationship that goes beyond what
sirius had with james
remember when voldemort gets angry and
destroys the force field surrounding
hogwarts after he senses that a horcrux
has been destroyed
yeah that doesn't happen in the original
books because voldemort can't actually
sense horcruxes being destroyed
and there also wasn't a physical force
field he had to bust through
but it definitely looked cool in the
movie and we all know that hollywood
loves to add drama
these changes added a fun visual element
to the film and it was a way to explain
how voldemort knew what harry was up to
without going into time-consuming detail
in the original uk version of half-blood
prince
harry and dumbledore spend a lot of time
observing memories through
the pen sieve the film cuts out most of
these scenes except for a little
backstory with snape and tom riddle
but one piece of information probably
should have been included just to ease
our minds about a rumor that's been
going around hogwarts
since the very first book it turns out
that the defense against the dark arts
position at hogwarts really was
cursed and it was all because of tom
riddle he wanted the position and when
dumbledore turned him down
he cursed it so no one else could have
it this is why we can't have nice things
tom
system
crookshanks is a special cat not that
you would ever know from watching the
movies
in the books he knew all along that
scabbers was really peter pettigrew in
animal form
and that sirius black was disguised as a
dog crookshanks even helped get sirius
into the castle to try to capture
pettigrew
and sirius used crookshanks to go to the
owl office and take gold from his own
gringotts vault to buy harry the
firebolt broomstick
the uk edition includes the vault number
711
while the us edition mysteriously leaves
it out it seems like both the vault
and crookshanks will forever remain a
mystery in the movies
speaking of mysteries the uk books gave
us one about neville that the us movies
decided to switch up
in the book it's mentioned that neville
dueled some snatchers who fell from the
covered bridge
in the film adaptation neville rigged
the entire covered bridge to blow up
instead
leaving neville without his mysterious
duel he sticks to taunting an army of
snatchers who promptly chase after him
once the shield around hogwarts falls
before they get caught up in the
exploding bridge still a win but we
would have loved a visual of neville's
big fight
we get so used to seeing death eaters
zip around with their trails of black
smoke in the movies that it's easy to
forget that in the books
they can't actually fly using their
magic in deathly hallows part 1
they wanted to add some parallels with
world war ii so voldemort's lackeys can
be seen zooming across london
as if in their own little fighter jets
while it might not be
exactly what jk rowling intended from a
death eater attack
we gotta admit the americanized version
is pretty unsettling
harry's first visit from hagrid and
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone is
on his birthday
july 31st in the film the two
immediately make their way to diagon
alley to buy school supplies before
hagrid takes harry to king's cross
station
to bump into walls on his own while
looking for platform nine and three
quarters
in the original english book however
harry has to go back to the dursleys for
the rest of the summer
uncle vernon actually takes him to the
station on september 1st
which is when the hogwarts express is
really supposed to leave
based solely on what we see in the film
harry gets to hogwarts a month early
we can understand cutting things for
time but maybe a quick flash forward
would have been helpful here
in the deathly hallows book harry is
under the invisibility cloak when snape
duels three professors and flees
hogwarts prior to the big battle
but part two of the u.s film didn't want
to leave harry in the shadows with
things
left unsaid so instead they added a
scene where harry confronts snape in
front of the whole school
about how he's a traitor it's some tense
stuff especially knowing what becomes of
snape just hours later
this was probably a good call since it
gives snape and harry some more
interaction time that would have been
hard to fit in a film
harry's got some good instincts but the
american movies don't always take the
time to show us that
in the uk version harry's first night at
hogwarts is terrorized by a dream where
he's wearing professor quarle's turban
which gets stuck on his head and tells
him to transfer into slytherin
he also watches draco malfoy morph into
professor snape
this is the type of nightmare a boggart
would love but in addition to being
creepy
it's also what leads harry to
distrusting quirrell draco
and snape so it probably would have
added some good foreshadowing to the
film
in the half blood prince we get a
touching tribute to lily that seems
perfect for the books
but was actually written exclusively for
the us movie
when harry finally gets the memory of
tom riddle he's been after from slughorn
he tells harry that lily created a fish
for him from the petal of a lily
just before it reached the bottom he's
transformed
he named him francis he kept the fish
all those years until it disappeared one
day
the same day lily lost her life it's a
beautiful story and a chance for harry
to learn more about his mother
plus we see slughorn's softer side which
is often overshadowed in the movies by
his interest
and powerful people the house elves are
a huge part of the uk harry potter
but somehow only two elves dobby and
cretcher
become key characters in the movies the
best house elf content
actually starts in harry potter and the
goblet of fire when hermione starts the
society for the promotion of elfish
welfare
or spew all of her house out advocating
is removed from the movies and so is one
particular elf named winky whose dire
circumstances
inspired the whole organization
another moment added to the u.s films is
an intimate scene between hermione and
harry
once ron runs off and deathly hallows
part one harry and hermione share a
lonely dance to comfort each other
in the face of whatever's coming next
this moment of bonding between the two
friends wasn't in the books at all but
we can see why because the moment is
much more powerful
scene than red
when the twins officially open up
weasley's wizard wheezies in half-blood
prince
no one questions how they paid for it
all the american movies never go on to
explain a thing
but if you read the original books you
know that it was actually harry that
gave them 1 000 galileans to start their
business
he earned the money from winning the
tri-wizard tournament but after what
happened to cedric he'd rather
not be reminded instead he helps out the
twins who are like brothers to him
now for some of those weird
international versions of the harry
potter
series since the us movies weren't the
only ones that made some big changes
in the french version voldemort's middle
name is elvis
it had to be changed so that his full
name tom elvis jerusaur
would become an anagram of jesus lord
voldemort which means
i am lord voldemort the danish edition
went even further with the name change
and voldemort's name
ended up being translated to romeo hm
maybe he is better left known as he who
shall not be named
in the spanish edition neville's pet had
a major makeover
trevor is a turtle instead of a toad
maybe turtles are just more popular in
spain or maybe the translator read the
name trevor
and thought that's not a toad's name
that's definitely a name for a turtle
either way if we took all the different
versions of harry potter and combined
them
we'd be in for a very confusing story
what moments do you wish they hadn't
changed for the movies
are there any that you're happy gotta
makeover let us know in the comments and
don't forget to hit that like
button and subscribe to the things for
more thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time